john uh jacquish uh has spent years
researching and development improved
approaches to health he's adventure of
the most effective bone density building
medical technology which has now
partnered with tony robbins and
osteostrong for rapid clinical
deployment inventor of the x3 a
technology that has proven to develop
muscle much faster than conventional
weightless lifting with all the lowest
risk of joint injury
uh dr jaquish methods are used in
training and the world's most elite
athletes in associations with the entire
miami heat organization
various nfl and nba players as well as
olympians dr jacquish's book explaining
his non-conventional approach to human
physiology is a wall street journal
bestseller and yeah you were kind enough
to send me a copy i've got it here on my
desk
um
it it's it's well researched and the
interesting thing i found about it i was
i was just looking at the book on amazon
there's a lot of criticisms of it from
people uh saying well it's not
well-researched
yeah and it doesn't cite anything and
i'm like are you stupid like did you
actually open the book and like it's
it's really nothing but a research paper
is the way that i would define it
right and the criticism has nothing to
do with the content yeah usually with me
personally people are very upset that
i'm successful yeah which um yeah like
i'm familiar with that too so i'm used
to that yeah let me just grab the bands
over here because because you sent me a
little bit of a kit so
these bands are all that you need to
um develop strong muscle fiber and um
in case you didn't see him on the cover
of the book like he's jacked af
um how old are you now john
44. um we'll talk about your approach to
self-care and um all that stuff in this
cast too so we got about an hour so you
guys are really gonna like this but this
stack of bands here
um you know is a guy that's lifted
weights his entire life and i've done
some unconventional stuff
um for
for athletics you know like there was a
gentleman by the name of charles atlas
i'm not sure if you're familiar with the
name
oh yeah
yeah so charles atlas um was a guy that
that coined this term dynamic tensions
and it was a little
it was basically uh uh like an e-book
that my dad handed me when i was like 11
or 12 because i was a skinny kid he's
like here you know read this and i
started doing push-ups and all these you
know dynamic tension movements that are
tied into it and i found this
theory like what you use with these
bands and i mean the cool thing that i
like about this is you can travel you
know with this like you can put this in
your suitcase you get everywhere around
the world yeah and there's lots of
places that you know like you can go
around and lock down you know type of
scenarios and this is the bar that goes
with it there's a foot stand as well you
guys can check that all out um
i just think it's a cool accessory like
i wouldn't use it to replace my squat
rack and the weights that i have in
there but i think it's a nice um
complement to all that um is this what
you do exclusively for self-care and for
you know developing a strong physique
yeah i haven't touched a weight in four
years and i put on over 60 pounds of
muscle and lost about 20 pounds of body
fat okay um
i think i'm going to do a little bit of
an experiment if i'm being honest for i
don't know like what do you think would
be reasonable 30 to 60 days of just
using bands
just to kind of compare some it
yeah i mean follow the program though
like
like you know you got to use the bar and
the plate the problem with bands by
themselves
is like you go to take one of those
bands you throw it around your back and
you go to do like a push-up
your wrists are twisting outward
if you get heavy enough to be relevant
for strength
and you know you could break a risk
doing that so
the bar and the plate were really
necessary my original plan
when i came to this this discovery which
really had to do with my bone density
research
uh in my first invention so
like in the clinical trial of that it
was like i i looked at the data and i
was like wow like this kind of proves
that weight lifting is a really lousy
stimulus like we are capable
of lifting a lot more than we do
but
we lift very light weight because
we're limited by our weaker range of
motion and in our stronger range of
motion coincidentally we're seven times
stronger
and what part is the like seven times
stronger range of motion is that like
towards the top like you know towards
the end of the motion or where short of
lockout so like like if i'm
demonstrating for those watching like
like 120 degree angle from upper to
lower arm
so like that
you know but like the back of my hand
would be in line with my clavicle
i can either absorb or produce the
greatest amount of force okay and then
no
one of the things that i found
interesting is like primates you know
specifically primates like you know uh
chimps for example they've got something
like four times the strength of humans
you know for the same amount of muscle
mass
do you know why that is
yeah uh they're very different muscle
cells there's uh there's more uh acne
myosin in there in the cells
yeah we're not we're not gonna get chimp
strength unlike pound by pound for pound
that makes the muscle that much more
yeah
like a rhesus monkey that weighs
less than a pound can take its fist and
punch through a human skull
really yeah
yeah don't own a monkey as a pet yeah
i've heard there are powerful animals do
not yes
and and once they reach sexual maturity
they're not your friend
so
how did you get into bands like what
like i'm assuming that you weightlifted
you know for a good chunk of your life
right 20 years yeah didn't get
didn't get much out i mean yeah i was in
shape like if i was at the beach with my
shirt off people would be like oh yeah
you lift
but i would have to take my shirt off
before people would notice
you know now
i walk into a grocery store and like
high school kids will stop me and you
know be like oh my god like do you play
in the nfl are you an mma fighter like i
look like a total mutant now
and so
you know it's it's just a it's a night
and day difference um so i lifted
weights for 20 years it really didn't do
much for me
and then it was when i was doing the
clinical trial for the bone density
device where the bone density device is
really simple and elegant kind of like
x3 like it places
tremendous loads on the impact ready
position
so if you trip and fall like what i was
just showing you with that kind of kind
of push-up position
when you're when you've got 120 degree
angle between your upper and lower arm
and the back of the hand is in line with
the clavicle
you can absorb or produce the greatest
amount of force possible
whereas when you go to the weaker range
like if you're bench pressing with the
bars on your chest
you have 1 7 the capacity
so you're always going to select a
weight you can handle in the weaker
range of motion if you're gonna lift
weights
thereby it's
really not going to stimulate the
majority of
the force capacity that you have
so you're really not switching on a lot
of muscle
and even also if you switch it on that
doesn't mean you take it to fatigue
because i think we've had a lot of false
positive excitement
when it comes to uh electron myography
like we can tell what muscle fiber
switches on it's a pretty
pretty simple way scientists have had to
measure and it's important in neurology
too because when someone's going through
neural rehab we got to make sure muscles
are firing the correct signals are going
to the correct places so people can have
normal movement
but firing
and power firing and and stimulating
growth are two different things
and so
we were a little distracted by that and
also
there's this sort of universal
blindness
when it comes to weightlifting where
weightlifting is sort of like
accepted as the only way to do it
and then whatever nuance you put on
on a weight lifting whether it's more
sets or less sets or
you know you eat two large pizzas
beforehand because you're one of those
idiots to think carbs is good for you
um you know like whatever like like
there's it's just sort of like
the weightlifting is just
blindly accepted and i just took a step
back when i did that clinical trial for
my first invention
and i said weightlifting is a lousy
stimulus like we need to vary the
resistance massively and so my first
thought was bands and i was going to
just write a book about bands because i
was already busy with osteostrong i
already had a big company
and so
you know like as soon as i did it i was
like
as soon as i kind of did the research
and realized
just using vans is worthless there's a
reason bands have been around forever
and they never really helped anybody
with with some rare exception you know
some speed training and stuff like that
where you have you said that bands were
worthless
yeah so
how is your band system not worthless
because it bands by themselves will
twist your smaller joints your ankles
and your wrists oh so that's where the
plate and the bar comes in right right
it was the plate in the bar that needed
to be developed and then once that was
developed to file patents on all that
stuff
in uh 36 different countries and uh yeah
then then we were off and it was super
super popular right away i didn't did a
soft launch on dave asprey's podcast
um that was my first podcast yeah and uh
yeah and it's been growing so fast since
then and
um it's really we don't really target
the typical fitness crowd because the
typical fitness crowd is not interested
in listening to science at all more able
maybe they're not even able
uh hard to tell
they might just be impatient and
unwilling to read
or on or just unable because
i mean science is kind of complicated
i'm just going to play this video here
so you guys can see um what it looks
like to use this band and bar system
yeah is like basically a uh deadlift
that you're doing here yep
uh it's frozen why isn't it not playing
is it supposed to be frozen
no
uh okay let me draw oh here you go okay
so now it's playing oh okay because it's
measuring the um
measuring the force
okay so rather than doing
like a deadlift with a bar with a bunch
of plates on it you're basically
standing on that plate
yeah and
and you're dead lifting and that
increases the weight you know towards
the top of the range
right where you are more powerful the
weight goes up where you are less
powerful the weight goes down it ensures
that you go to a deeper level of fatigue
like here i'm doing a deadlift with 614
pounds at the top
well i would never grab a bar with 614
pounds on it how's that how's that
device measuring the the uh resistance
like the weight is it
so you can see by my left hand uh
there's something with a wire coming off
it that's a lot oh i see yeah okay got
it
yeah that's not part of the product
that's that's just there i mean i don't
have the load cell i'm just using it
yeah that's just the product itself okay
yeah
yeah so uh and that would be like a
bench press you're doing there that
would be a squat yep squat
okay so uh i mean like what about other
uh like technical movement let me pull
this out of the screen what about like
other technical movements you know for
example something like um like a zotman
curl like a zotman curl for those of you
that don't know what that is like you
basically take the bar and you'd lift it
up and you're twisting the
weight like this which activates like
the
wrists and the forearm you don't have
access to do movements like that with a
band system right no we
we stuck to basic barbell movements
the strongest people in the world don't
use dumbbells they use barbells
and it's a lot of it has to do there's a
great study that shows that you lose
about 20 percent of your muscle fiber
when you train one arm at a time
so the upper body likes both arms to be
engaged
the lower body on the other hand is the
opposite story because unless you're a
kangaroo you walk on one leg at a time
and you run on one leg at a time
we're very good
at
one leg activation and force production
so it's really weird like you switch to
one leg squats
and you think you would just go half of
your normal squat weight
now it's more like 75
and you'll get the same amount of reps
and also you get all your body's
resources directed into one quadricep
and one glute
so you can go to a deeper level of
fatigue
one of the things i um liked about using
it is um
like i have a
i mean i don't want to say i have a bad
back but my back ain't great
um i injured it a couple of times in my
20s and it's never really been the same
although
um i've i've done enough in my life to
kind of like minimize that so
ever since that i haven't been a heavy
squatter don't generally like do heavy
deadlifts or anything like that but i
found that with the band system because
the weight changes
um as you
stand up straight you know for example
like the weight gets heavier as you're
reaching the end of the band's
resistance
you don't actually have any opportunity
to injure your lower back the way that
i've done before with like squatting or
with deadlifts that's right
oh here we go this is not a buddy one
here who's who's a who's whose claim to
fame nice to see you ron i'm glad you're
there and chiming in um
he said 1312 days in a row of working
out and using x3 bands every week not
every day and i think i get more benefit
from them than anything ron's older than
me i think he's in his 50s now and he's
in really really good shape um fellow
entrepreneur and uh friend but um yeah
it's it's it's great i think if you're
older for sure
um so you don't have any kind of
injuries because because it's almost um
i don't want to say it's idiot proof but
i think that you can pretty much yeah
58. oh no people can screw it up i
promise yeah i'm pretty sure you can
screw up anything but
but the chances of you injuring
parts that that are much more easily
damaged with like straight bar deadlifts
you know for example with a bar and a
bunch of plates drops dramatically right
that's right
yeah and like i said that's that's why
the nfl was so attracted to this why the
nba like they don't care how much they
bench at all they don't care how much
they squat they don't you know they're
paid to perform on the court or on the
field
and uh
so like when i'm talking to these
strength coaches they just think x3 is
like like i mean the miami heat the
endorsements right on the back of the
book they let me use their name in
writing
like
pro teams never do that
like yeah and i know
huge acceptance i saw ben greenfield's
name and he's very careful about where
he puts his name too
he endorsed it so did dr baker
uh
have you had sean baker on your show
i haven't no
oh yeah the carnivore guy cardboard
doctor you should i'll check him out
he's great um i follow uh pd petey
bangin on twitter and you know he talks
a lot about die and exercise especially
you know for older seasoned gentlemen
too
you